[Musique]
bonsoir dernier journal de la saison sur
tb 60,18 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez voici les titres de ce jeudi
16 juillet elle a choisi les yvelines
pour l'un de ses premiers déplacements
officiels l'ex député nadia est à mantes
la ville à la mi journée la ministre
délégué à la ville est venu échanger
avec les élus et associations locales
dans cette commune qui recense deux
quartiers prioritaires
ce n'est pas un mais trois déplacements
qui a effectué aujourd'hui et valérie
pécresse sur le territoire cela a débuté
ce matin à l'usiné renault de flins sur
seine concernés par un plan de
restructuration la présidente de la
région a insisté sur la nécessité de
maintenir une production automobile sur
place et puis le département des
yvelines a programmé 54 chantiers cet
été sur son réseau routier et zoom sur
les plus emblématiques à la fin de cette
édition la ministre délégué à la ville
nadia s est donc rendu aujourd'hui à
mantes-la-ville dans cette commune qui
compte deux quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville elle a rencontré
les associations
marylène iapichino et patrick jacques de
dixmude un tour de table des
associations avec la nouvelle ministre
de la ville nadia et pour l'un de ses
premiers déplacements dans le cadre de
sa mission de politique de la ville
l'ancien député blinoise n'a pas choisi
mantes-la-ville au hasard la communité
sous la mandature du rassemblement
national jusqu'au 28 juin dernier où le
candidat sans étiquette mais soutenu par
l'union de la droite sami damerdji a été
élu l'enjeu qui va être aujourd'hui pour
la nouvelle équipe municipale c'est
justement de rétablir la cohésion
sociale c'est de ramener la république
parce que quand on décide de retirer des
financements du milieu associatif
c'est quelque part la république qui se
retire la ministre entend réinscrire
mantes-la-ville dans les dispositifs mis
en place à l'échelle gouvernementale
durant six ans les associations 17
sentis abandonnés
elle attend désormais un soutien de la
part de la nouvelle municipalité mais
aussi de l'état on avait besoin vraiment
de cet appui structurelles maintenant
aussi d'un appui logistique c'est à dire
d'une aide d'un accompagnement qui va
permettre à nos à nos associations parce
qu'on est plusieurs associations à
pouvoir mettre en place les projets pour
la commune et pour les habitants de son
côté le maire
sami damerdji a souhaité montrer l'état
de l'un des gymnases qu'il estime
délabré car non entretenues par la
municipalité précédente
cette visite était l'occasion de dresser
un bilan pour pouvoir aller de l'avant
et entamer la première étape du
programme pour lequel il a été élu
la cohésion sociale et la réconciliation
des générations et des quartiers
beaucoup d'attentes mais également
beaucoup d'espoir et on a eu une oreille
attentive de la part de l'état donc au
travers de madame la ministre avec
laquelle donc on va pouvoir nouer un
dialogue qui n'a jamais existé pendant
six ans en tout cas moins que la ville
est inscrite dans le dispositif
quartiers d'été du ministère de la
cohésion des territoires pour renforcer
les activités dans les quartiers
prioritaires et compte lancer la mise en
place de centres de vie sociaux dès la
rentrée pour une effectivité en janvier
2021 triple déplacement dans les
yvelines pour la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse s'est
rendue ce matin à l'usiné renault de
flins sur seine
une visite sur le site qui a produit les
véhicules de l'alliance renault nissan
elle a aussi rencontré sur place la
direction et les partenaires sociaux au
coeur des échanges le plan d'économies
de 2 milliards d'euros du groupe renault
avec la transformation de l'activité du
site et les précisions de nicolas landry
la région ile-de-france au soutien de l'
usine renault de flins lors de sa visite
la présidente valérie pécresse est venue
rappeler sa volonté de maintenir la
production de véhicules sur ce site
industriel une position contraire aux
annonces de la direction du groupe
la transformation de l'activité de
l'usiné de flins consacré dans un plan
d'économies global de deux milliards
d'euros
la direction de renault a un projet là
un projet basé sur l'économie circulaire
qui est un projet très intéressant mais
qui doit se conjuguer avec la volonté de
tous les élus du territoire de continuer
de produire des voitures ici à flins
alors la région va essayer de faire tout
ce qui était en son pouvoir pour
convaincre l'état qu'il ne faut pas d
industrialiser la vallée de la seine
actuellement la nissan micra et le
véhicule électrique zoé sortent chaque
jour des lignes de production de l'usiné
créée en 1952 l'établissement emploie
près de 2600 personnes
la région souhaite participer à sa
compétitivité et à son attractivité
la région pourrait intervenir pour
rénover complètement
centrale thermique du site qui est
vétuste et qui pourrait se transformer
en une belle centrales de production
d'énergie peut-être même pour le
territoire
durant cette visite valérie pécresse a
rencontré les partenaires sociaux des
syndicats engagés actuellement dans des
négociations avec la direction du groupe
madame pécresse on la sent très investis
c'est une personne qui veut vraiment
faire bouger les choses et qui veut
vraiment par et préserver l'emploi et la
région le maintien de la production de
véhicules notamment du véhicule
électrique véhicule propre et quand même
un des véhicules les plus vendus sur la
région parisienne
l'état la région les pouvoirs publics
draine des milliards d'argent public
dans les poches de renault et renault
annoncent la fermeture de sites
la suppression de postes l'arrêt de
fabrication de voitures à flot et c'est
une nouvelle réunion entre les
partenaires sociaux et la direction du
groupe est prévue courant septembre pour
faire un point sur la restructuration
valérie pécresse qui a poursuivi
aujourd'hui son déplacement à thoiry la
présidente de la région est venu
présenter à cette occasion le fond
résilience lancé le 10 juin dernier par
l'île de france une avance financière
remboursable à taux zéro et sans
garantie destiné aux entreprises
franciliennes de 0 à 20 salariés et les
montants peuvent aller de 3000 à cent
mille euros en fonction de la taille et
des besoins des structures
l'objectif lutter contre la crise
économique conséquence du confinement
on écoute à nouveau valérie pécresse au
micro de michael et demi d'euros c'est
pour les artisans c'est pour les
commerçants c'est pour les indépendants
c'est ce sera évidemment très largement
les restaurants le tourisme la culture
le btp c'est aussi pour les start up
très fragile qui avait pas de capitaux
propres avant la crise et ça permet de
se relever et on reparlera tout à
l'heure des entreprises on ira à prendre
le pouls au ski cube l'incubateur des
start up de saint quentin en yvelines
dans l'actualité politique
également ce recours d'annulation du
scrutin déposée par nelly duthu à la
verrière l ex maire communiste a perdu
son fauteuil le 28 juin dernier devant
ces 2 58 voix par nicolas dainville
devenu premier magistrat de la commune
celle qui siège désormais dans
l'opposition invoque le respect des
droits et de la démocratie et dénonçant
des mensonges et attaques subies pendant
la campagne et le dossier est désormais
entre les mains du tribunal
administratif de versailles est la
verrière qui fait partie de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines c'est là
justement qu'une élection législative
partielle doit se tenir à l'automne
suite logique de la démission de la
députée des yvelines nadia ils étaient
deux à se porter candidat pour
représenter la droite au scrutin c'est
finalement philippe benassaya qui a été
désigné par la fédération elle l'est
républicain des yvelines othman
nasrullah récemment a désigné premier
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france sera son suppléant
marylène iapichino retrace le parcours
du candidat qui est actuellement maire
de bois d'arcy
arrivé dans la ville de bois d'arcy en
2008 où il échoue aux élections
municipales et se retrouve dans
l'opposition
philippe benassaya se représente en 2014
avec une liste de rassemblement ump udf
il mène une campagne avec une forte
opposition au projet immobilier du
centre-ville défendu par le maire
sortant
il crée alors la surprise en faisant
basculer la ville à droite le maire ps
sortant claude vivier y était élu depuis
19 ans en 2015 il transforme l'essai
avec les départementales en binôme avec
sonia bros actuel maire de saint cyr
l'école
il remporte le canton ancré à gauche
depuis 1997 et participe au grand chelem
de la droite à ces élections c'est une
confirmation c'est une consolidation de
nos résultats dans nos villes c'est un
encouragement un espoir du travail qu'on
a fait depuis un an au département il
est notamment président d'ingenico
l'organisme qui aide les petites
communes dans l'élaboration de projets
en 2020 il a été réélu maire de bois
d'arcy dès le premier tour avec plus de
60% des voix
ça fait quand même une assise importante
on est obligé de se poser la question
quand il ya une liste hâtive partiel
surtout quand on fait ces résultats là
dans une ville et dans un canton on se
dit qu'on est peut-être peut-être le
plus habilité pour pour y aller et puis
je j'ai été conforté surtout parlé par
l'appui que j'ai reçus d'à peu près les
parlementaires tous les parlementaires
de ma famille politique que des yvelines
gérard larcher bien sûr pierre bédier
valérie pécresse jean michel fourgous le
présente 50 heures avec othman nassr ou
comme suppléant il entend représenter la
force du travail d'un élu proche du
terrain dans les crises successives que
la france vienne 2 vient de subir crises
sociales et économiques crise sanitaire
la réponse quand même est venu très
souvent des collectivités pas du haut
elle est venue d'en bas et nous
représentons lui et moi cette france de
terrain cette france du territoire cette
france des collectivités pour leur est
le seul candidat déclaré pour ces
législatives partielles
nadia est désormais ministre a assuré
qu'il y aurait une candidature de la
république en marche
quant à la gauche à lire ab nouveau
maire de trappes souhaite convaincre
benoît hamon de faire son retour
il est le nouveau président de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
thomas gourland été élu hier mercredi
lors du conseil des installations de la
collectivité
l actuel premier adjoint de la commune
de rambouillet a recueilli et 47 voix
sur 65 l écologiste david jutier lui a
récolté 12 bulletins
thomas gourland ans succède à marc
robert également ancien maire de
rambouillet qui s'est retiré pour
raisons de santé
il occupait sous la précédente mandature
le poste de premier vice président en
charge des finances et de la prospective
territoriale le point à présent sur
l'épidémie de coronavirus dans les
yvelines la crise sanitaire toujours
présente dans le département où les
derniers chiffres sont à la hausse hier
mercredi sept hospitalisations
supplémentaires ont été comptabilisés en
24 heures 344 patients sont hospitalisés
en raison de la codi de 19/20 sont
toujours en réanimation dans les
hôpitaux l'épidémie a fait 523 victime
soit deux décès supplémentaires en 24
heures et depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire 2234 personnes ont été guéries
du coronavirus après un passage à
l'hôpital
vous le savez l'un des moyens efficaces
de lutter contre la propagation du virus
c'est d'identifier les cas par le biais
est de dépistage depuis samedi dernier
un arrêté publié au journal officiel
donne la possibilité aux pharmaciens de
réaliser des tests sérologiques rapide
en officine et on en parle avec romain
fauquet bonsoir monsieur vous êtes
pharmacien à l'espace saint quentin à
montigny le bretonneux est-ce que déjà
cette possibilité
le fait de pouvoir se faire dépister
directement en pharmacie c'était quelque
chose qui était réclamée par par les
clients lorsqu'ils venaient dans dans
votre officines à l'espace saint quentin
et cali pas les clients étaient
également avec la baie depuis depuis un
moment par la profession là on a en
appelé et on s'est battus pour le droit
d'effectuer c'est peut-être c'était de
dépistage sérologique donc donc et je
pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
tout le monde et pourquoi c'était
demandé de votre part de la part des
pharmaciens parce que on l'a ans on est
ensemble et c'est encore plus important
pendant leur confinement on est de santé
qui est resté ouvert
et qui est librement accessible à tout
le monde
on n'a pas besoin de rendez-vous on n'a
pas besoin de vous avez une pharmacie à
tous les points de tous les coins de rue
dont c'était c'est les pharmacies nous
pensons qu'on allait nous sommes les
plus à même de tête de réaliser
rapidement ce genre de test de dépistage
des personnes entre evry et bien portant
dans les pharmacies devons casser c'est
un lieu qui est propice à la possibilité
donnée depuis samedi je le disais grâce
à un arrêté publié au journal officiel
est ce que à l'heure où on se parle il
est déjà possible dans votre piscine de
se faire dépister ce héros logiquement
oui oui on a anticipé les les commandes
depuis depuis un mois déjà on allait en
a les tests qui sont disponibles on a
notre équipe qui sont formés dans des
conditions sanitaires qui sont qui sont
qui sont propices à cette démarche
donc top départ depuis depuis deux jours
donc on est on est prêts on a déjà
commencé à effectuer nos premiers tests
ce jour et comment ça se passe
concrètement comment se déroulent ces
tests alors le ps a encore une fois cela
tests sérologiques se dire qu'on détecte
la présence d'anticorps dans le haut
niveau sanguin c'est pas un test pcr
quand on a également entendu parler qui
détecte présence du virus dans le temps
sont là nous on y détecte la présence de
la réponse immunitaire de l'organisme à
l'infection par leur part le virus donc
c est ça apparaît en gros les
d'anticorps apparaître une semaine après
l'apparition des symptômes
le test dure deux minutes
c'est une petite goutte de sang qu'on
prélève au bout du doigt comme pour le
test dieu du diabète très deux décennies
canebière et du coût du kwh minute
mi-temps et ça veut dire oui
allez-y ya les aspects positifs
évidemment nécessite la confirmation de
ceux de cette positivité dans un
laboratoire médical
j'allais vous ils vous posez la question
du coup si le test est positif vous
orienter
les passions les clients vers vers ses
laboratoires c'est ça bien sûr s'il est
positif
évidemment il ya toutes les mesures qui
doivent être prises pour éviter la
contamination de l'emploi et des proches
des gestes de parieurs on les rappelle
on les rappelle tu donc notre houle
notre rôle nous n'est pas de nous
substituer ou à deux professionnels de
santé un médecin et deux laboratoires
mais c'est de participer aux 7 à cette
politique de dépistage qui est essentiel
pour vaincre l'épidémie
alors pour être tout à fait précis pour
les téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
ça veut dire on l'a compris ce test va
dire si on a pu avoir le virus dans un
passé récent mais ne va pas dire si on
là à l'instant t on peut déterminer si
on a été en contact avec avec lorie
virus et qu'on a de développer une
réponse immunitaire ce monsieur virus
donc le contact n'a pu être
symptomatique ou asymptomatiques
mais mais mais permet de déterminer a
été en contact avec jean n'a compris
avec des tests supplémentaires ainsi ce
premier test est positif est ce que
c'est efficace ce test sérologique que
l'on peut faire en pharmacie ce qu'ils
sont plutôt fidèles à la réalité
oui oui c'est fiable après évidemment on
il ya des pays des fautes négatifs et
des propos du tiff donc il faut être
il faut être vigilant et on met en garde
et les les
tous les patients sur sur cet élément le
coût du test on est aux alentours de 15
20 euros et 15 euros le 15 euros et qui
est non remboursés pour le moment par
l'assurance maladie
point n'est pas remboursée et donc ça
prouve en le disais tout à l'heure à
découvrir demain se fier que l'actualité
montre votre rôle clé aussi dans
dans cette épidémie le rôle des
pharmaciens est ce que depuis le début
du confinement ça a été une mobilisation
on peut dire de tous les instants pour
les pour les pharmaciens oui ça a été
cette période compliquée avec des
soubresauts de l'actualité on entendu
parler des masques et des gels donc donc
on a dû adapter notre notre exercice
avec l'actualité et avoir un rôle à rôle
de pédagogie important pour vous
répondre aux besoins aux besoins de la
population leurs questionnements et à
l'europe et leur inquiétude également
aussi on était revenus de dessus on a dû
changer notre manière de fonctionner a
beaucoup plus de livres et dont tu
parles de pâtes et donc du coup c'était
une période qui était fait et qui était
j'étais costaud à gérer ouais voilà pour
cette mesure a un qui en complète
d'autres on a appris par exemple
aujourd'hui que le port du masque serait
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
et ce dès la semaine prochaine merci
d'avoir été avec nous romain choqué et
je rappelle que les pharmaciens à
l'espace saint quentin à montigny le
bretonneux
c'est un univers à qui pourrait profiter
la crise sanitaire selon une étude
réalisée par l'incubateur station elf
plus de 92% des jeunes entreprises ont
été impactés par la crise mais le
recours massif au numérique en à idées
aussi de nombreuses à saint quentin en
yvelines le ski cuba compagnie
actuellement une vingtaine de structures
dont le bilan n'est pas si négatif on
voit ça avec mélanie poker et hugo
kitson l'année 2020 avait plutôt bien
commencé pour pascal goupilleau le 1er
janvier il lança société incubés au ski
cube une plate forme de recommandations
pour les artisans du btp prévu pour le
mois d'octobre
on avait prévu de lancer début septembre
donc avec le co vide on a pris un peu de
retard dans les développements
on a pris un peu de retard aussi pour
rencontrer les clients qui étaient pas
très visible sur cette période là
qu'avaient d'autres choses à penser
pascal goupilleau envisage de faire
appel au fonds résilience pour
poursuivre son développement
un prêt dont a bénéficié cette
plateforme d'accès aux services de
maintien à domicile
cette start up a connu pendant le coffee
des factures de clients paient
heureusement que ces aides étaient là
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas pu
continuer justement ce travail qu'on a
poursuivi on n'aurait pas pu continuer
de payer nos fournisseurs on aurait
ralenti l'activité
donc on a eu une recours notamment au
pge aux prêts garantis par l'état
le ski cube accueille actuellement une
vingtaine de start-up si l'établissement
saint quentinois note leur bonne santé
il a continué à les accompagner pendant
le confinement lançant des start up a dû
regagnez domicile et nous avons
évidemment gardé contact avec avec elle
mais que ce soit de contact avec les
startups évidemment que nous incluons à
skis cube mais aussi avec tous les
porteurs de projets de l'agglomération
ont mis en place à un plan de relance
démobiliser les évidemment ses propres
fonds pour accompagner de manière
complémentaire des entreprises qui par
ailleurs n'aurait pas pu forcément
bénéficié des fonds mis en place un plan
de relance de 2 millions d'euros le ski
cube n'est pour le moment pas totalement
déconfit nez les projets se préparent
sur rendez vous comme chaque été le
département des yvelines profitent des
vacances pour intensifier l'entretien de
son réseau routier 54 chantiers sont
ainsi programmés sur l'ensemble du
territoire
présentation des plus emblématiques avec
aurélie rond et mathilde 2/2 aux routes
coupées ou encore déviation tout au long
de cet été il va falloir vous habituer à
ces panneaux dans les yvelines
comme chaque année d'importants travaux
de sécurisation et de modernisation du
réseau vont être effectués dans 52
communes
une période qui n'est pas choisi au
hasard on peut espérer la en ce moment
c'est le cas que la météo facilite
l'organisation de ces chantiers et on le
fait aussi à une période où le flot de
circulation est moins dense
donc on pénalise moins au total 54
chantiers de différents types sont
répartis sur tout le territoire
rénovation d'un ouvrage franchissant la
scène à gargenville le pont sera coupée
à la circulation jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'août à plaisir les travaux se
poursuivent sur la passerelle au dessus
de la rd 30 au niveau du bois de la
crâne autre chantier emblématique de cet
été le giratoire de l'abreuvoir à marly
le roi on a un gros point sur lequel on
doit résoudre à la fois le problème de
la sécurité
de la résistance de la chaussée parce
que les véhicules d'aujourd'hui c'est
pas les carros dans le temps et en même
temps de faire que ce choix joly en tous
les cas que l'on respecte cette
insertion dans le shit dans les yvelines
enveloppe allouée à l'année pour les
travaux sur le réseau routier d'environ
12 millions d'euros 70 % de ce budget
consommé durant la saison estivale
pas de rapport direct avec ces travaux
mais la circulation sera difficile
demain vendredi en ile de france à la
veille du troisième week-end des
vacances d'été ça risque de boucher dans
la région et bison futé voit orange
demain vendredi dans le sens des départs
il est recommandé de traverser ou de
quitter l'ile-de-france avant 14 heures
samedi la couleur passe au rouge le
ministère des transports recommande de
quitter les grandes métropoles avant 9
heures du matin dans le sens des retours
en revanche tous les feux sont au vert
dans la région et ce pendant tout le
week end
c'est la fin de ce dernier journal de la
saison votre édition quotidienne
d'information reviendra à la rentrée
mais d'ici là pas de panique tv 60,18
vous accompagne durant tout l'été
dès la semaine prochaine émission du
mode d'emploi et du 7-8 europe
l équipe sera aussi sur le pont pour
continuer de vous relayer l'actualité
locale par le biais de reportages
quotidiens ces reportages seront à
visionner directement sur la chaîne
toute la journée ou sur nos réseaux
sociaux notre application mobile et
notre site internet
j'étais très heureux de vous présenter
ses plus de 150 édition cette saison une
année forcément particulière avec cette
crise sanitaire du coronavirus pendant
laquelle la rédaction et rester
pleinement mobilisées
un grand merci à toute l'équipe de tv
soixante dix huit journalistes comme
monteur infographiste webmasters et
community manager avec un clin d'oeil
particulier à aurélie manon marylène
mathilde et jules qui quitte l'aventuré
à laquelle ils ont grandement contribué
et puis merci à vous chers
téléspectateurs de votre fidélité
portez vous bien prudence encore et très
bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]